we have a great show tonight we're gonna
have a good one sorry Conan hey oh I'm
sorry that's Gary one of our stage hands
yes Gary what is it yes you've probably
noticed that your blue mug is missing I
didn't I didn't really notice no it's I
know it's usually here but I didn't I
didn't notice well I'm very sorry I did
not get a chance to place it on your
desk during commercials so I have it if
you want me to you know bring it to you
you know what Carrie I don't I'm sorry I
don't want you to bring it to me every
time you do anything you turn it into
this big production and you you just
draw this attention to yourself for no
reason so no I don't just don't believe
the debt leave the money that's that
sold me I don't I don't do that anymore
I'm a changed man I'm just all business
now what you're saying is you think you
can bring my mug over here place it on
my desk without making it a big ordeal
is that what you're saying yeah
yeah I do I have learned from my
mistakes fine Gary walk the mug over and
put it on my desk right now and then we
can get on with the show all right okay
no problem good go ahead and just bring
it on over to me and put it here
okay so I'll show you the mug and bring
it to you perfect yes that's great
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. cha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I just wanted the mug Gary I know I
am terribly sorry and you will get the
mug right after this three four
[Music]
[Applause]
right back Fred artists from Sears
ticket back home
[Applause]
[Music]
you